salut aujourd'hui on est samedi je suis
toujours à aix en provence où je joue ce
soir et demain donc je vous fais le
premier master class depuis ce
magnifique théâtre aujourd'hui je
commence le master class c'est la classe
mercredi souvenez vous je vous ai parlé
de comment retenir un numéro de
téléphone à la volée qu'on vous donne un
numéro de téléphone maintenant vous
pouvez créer une petite saynète dans
votre tête pour le retenir vous allez
avoir plein de dessins animés en tête et
grâce à moi non on peut aller beaucoup
plus loin que ça
grâce à ce qu'on appelle la table de
rappel l'idéal est toute simple elle
consiste à convertir tous les nombres de
1 à 100 en images ça permet de rendre
concret dans son esprit des choses aussi
irréel que 2 2 on peut pas se le
représenter par contre si on a une image
la passe de deux on peut se représenter
cette image c'est un petit peu comme un
code secret une table de rappel comme
une carte aux trésors de la mémoire
alors est ce que vous voulez devenir des
pirates de la mémoire avec moi arrêtez
de vous prendre pour jack sparrow jeu
quand même vous expliquer à quoi ça va
vous servir au quotidien vous allez
pouvoir avec sa chope et n'importe quel
numéro de téléphone qu'on vous donne
mais plus que ça n'importe quelle
séquence de chiffres ça peut être un
numéro de carte bleue ça peut être des
codes pour quelque chose ça peut être un
numéro de réservation pour les billets
d'avion
ça peut être aussi des choses plus
basiques votre liste de courses votre
liste de choses que vous devez emmener à
tel endroit ça peut être ça peut être
les points terrain discours vous pouvez
quasiment tous revenir avec ça c'est la
table de rappel c'est extrêmement
pratique rôle de même à prendre sa pause
enfants en primaire sur le moi c'est mon
époque vous puissiez construire votre
table de rappel votre espèce d'être
mémoire tu vois de convertisseurs savoir
à quelles images correspondent chaque
chiffre
il existe plusieurs méthodes y en a une
qui est très populaire chez les sportifs
de la mémoire oui il ya des sportifs de
la mémoire monsieur c'est la méthode de
pierre et rigole thierry reagens était
un mathématicien est un astronome
français d'ailleurs du xviie siècle
il a monté une méthode pour construire
ces images et se rappeler de quelle
image on avait il a créé un code à
partir de consonnes c'est à dire il a
attribué une consonne à chaque chiffre 1
ct 3 cm 4 c est déjà attribué ce qu au
delà et pour construire son image
il reprend les consonnes y rajoute des
voyelles entre les deux c'est pas clair
pour créer l'image qui va associer aux
chiffres 31
il regarde 31 ça fait 3 et 1 des
chiffres qui composent le nombre 31 sont
trois es1 es3 dans sa méthode à lui ça
correspond à la lettre mm parce qu'en
fait 3 comprend que ça fait penser à m
et le 1 ça correspond à un thé pas ce
côté ça ressemble un petit peu à 1 1
avec sept grandes barres ok donc ça fait
m
étaient donc si on rajoute des voyelles
entre tout ça on peut faire moutons donc
l'image pour 31
ça va être un bouton si on prend le 43
ça fait r et m
donc si on rajoute deux voyelles on peut
obtenir ram on peut avoir l'image d'une
rame en 43 est ce que vous comprenez de
mieux en mieux ce principe mais vous
n'êtes pas obligé de suivre cette
méthode il y en existe d'autres
et surtout il existe la vôtre c'est très
important parce que votre table de
rappel va vous servir beaucoup et elle
doit vous correspondre vous souvenez
toujours dans l'astuce de mercredi
dernier je vous disais moi 22 ça me fait
penser aux flics mais 22 ça vous fait
peut-être penser à votre département de
naissance ou à une date clé pour vous à
une date de mariage
j'en sais rien en fait il faut vraiment
que la table de rappel elle vous
corresponde c'est très important ça va
vous aider à maîtriser cet outil qui est
extrêmement puissant ma méthode
personnelle c'est d'utiliser la rime
numérique avec une constance
ok je te vois partir discrètement de
cette vidéo une réelle numérique avec
constante
on va s'arrêter la preuve dans ce
dessein pas les vidéos
n'ayez pas peur c'est pas très grave une
rime numérique c'est quoi c'est à dire
que je fait rimer en fait la fin la
prononciation du nombre de chiffres avec
la prononciation de mon image un exemple
tout bête
enfin j'ai l'image d'un sapin en 2g
l'image du feu en 3g l'image d'une croix
en 4g images d'un plâtre enceinte c'est
un bar mais en prêt dans ma tête c'est
1,5 1,6 g une scie en fait une tête dans
huit une huître en neuf c1 9 ans 10 et
la police va pour le coup j'ai fait un
policier mais d'autres dans un
commissariat en 11g le penseur de rodin
parce que pour moi ça me fait penser à
bronzer bronze à statut oui c'est mon
propre chemin en 12 jeux de la pelouse
entre est une fraise et si on va plus
auxerre en 30 j'ai une tante et en 31 g1
porcin et en 32 junte ne et en 33 g un
plat et en 34 un pirate
est-ce que vous remarquez où aller ma
constante aller dans la première lettre
toutes les images de mes trentaine donc
de 30 à 39
ça commence par un pc un code que je me
suis mis comme ça si j'ai pas réviser ma
table de rappel depuis longtemps et
qu'on me dit 66 je sais que tous mes
soixante commence par la lettre s
systématiquement et je sais que ça va
finir par un truc comme heath et en fait
ça me revient instantanément ses
saucisses en l'occurrence mon 66 est une
saucisse bien alors pour créer votre
table de rappel il faut commencer par
créer votre grille à vous vous prenez le
pas trop la tête pour les 20 premiers
essayé de faire des choses qui vous
parle met vraiment vraiment qui vous
parle comme ça instantanément ce qui
vous vient il sera toujours le temps de
refaire une si vous voulez un jour ou
même d'en avoir plusieurs j'ai un ami
qui s'appelle benoît heureusement qui
est un grand spécialiste de la mémoire
qui joue sur scène aussi également il a
je ne sais pas combien d'étapes de
rappel alors il passe de l'une à l'autre
moi j'en ai que deux c'est déjà bien
vous pouvez en créer plusieurs mais j'en
ai des petites par contre j'en ai de
nombreuses petites de 1 à 20 ça me
permet de stocker différentes
informations dans ma tête commencez par
créer votre table de rappel on va dire
10 à 20 mo pour commencer et mémoriser
les pour les mémoriser c'est pas
compliqué il faut les reprendre
régulièrement retrouvez vos logique vous
le faire en permanence vous amuser
vraiment à le faire et pour ça vous avez
de la chance il existe plein de temps
morts dans la ville dans vos journées il
existe énormément d'endroits vous ne
faites rien de spécial ou mentalement
vous êtes trop hâtivement inactifs comme
moi sauf c'est le cas pour tout le monde
ça peut être dans les embouteillages ça
peut être aux toilettes
ah oui vous pouvez rentabiliser le temps
que vous passez aux toilettes quand vous
êtes dans une file d'attenté
quand vous écoutez quelqu'un et que ça
vous intéresse pas trop ce qu'ils
racontent
il ya plein de moments où vous pouvez
vous entraîner comme ça et donc vous
vous testez vous même le but c'est que
ça devienne aussi naturel pour vous que
votre alphabet votre un tempo et vous
réfléchissez pas grand quand vous le
dites vous le dit et puis c'est tout ou
vian et bien là c'est pareil et c'est
même encore plus fort ça doit devenir
aussi naturel mais en plus dissociatifs
quand vous dira 14 vous aurez tout de
suite l'image du 14 qui vous reviendra
en tête quand vous dira 22 vous aurez
votre image de vente de voir même quand
vous verrez
l'image qui est dans le tas de rappel
vous allez penser instantanément aux
chiffres là c'est bouctouche et le bon
et non pas le bon bout
donc prenez le temps vraiment de
mémoriser ces 20 premières occurrences
toutes les images que vous allez
associés de 1 à 20 prenez le temps de
les maîtriser
vraiment vraiment vraiment et une fois
que c'est fait pour ajouter dix
nouvelles images en plus on va dire une
fois par mois
ça s'est très très bien ou alors vous en
rajoutez 10 par semaine si vous êtes
très motivé mais il vaut mieux prendre
son temps et en un an à avoir une belle
tape de rappel bien fourni et bien
maîtrisée que de vouloir aller trop vite
et sera le but idéalement c'est
d'atteindre 100 images de 0 à 99 ça
c'est très bien ça permet de retenir
quelque chose en séquençant par deux et
concrètement comment vous allez vous en
servir tout redonne encore l'exemple du
numéro de téléphone si l' on vous donne
un numéro de téléphone donc ces cinq
nombre à deux chiffres
vous n'avez plus que 5 image à retenir
vous savez même pas aller chercher vous
les connaissez déjà
ces images vous comprenez la puissance
de sa comme ce sont vos images à vous
vous allez retenir ça très facilement 5
image à retenir c'est très très facile
vous pouvez après les relier entre elles
pour faire une petite action comme on a
vu mercredi et ça vous donne une saynète
que vous maîtrisez vraiment parfaitement
on peut vous donner le numéro de
téléphone en une seule fois ça vous fait
naître tout de suite les images n'y a
pas de recherche vous allez retenir tout
de suite si vous devez retenir une liste
de courses mise de course voilà les
associés les images ensemble par exemple
le premier objet de la liste de courses
et un pack de lait ok vous allez prendre
votre image du un mois en l'occurrence
un sapin mais moi dans ma tête je vais
imaginer mon sapin sur lequel on est en
train de renverser du lait je crée une
image mentale j'ai pas besoin
d'apprendre cette image
j'ai juste besoin de la visualiser une
fois mon sapin sur lequel coule plein
plein plein plein de lait je vais faire
comme ça avec chaque objet de la liste
de courses vous pouvez faire ça en
l'associant avec l'image correspondante
à son rang dans le 5ème truc que vous
devez acheter
vous l'imaginez avec votre image
d'humeur du numéro 5 6 par exemple ce
sont des pâtes
moi je les imagine et des pattes sur un
zinc de bach encore bien fumant encore
une fois vous n'avez pas à mémoriser
cette association d'idées juste à la
visualiser et comme notre mémoire est
magnifique elle retient ça tout de suite
parce que c'est du concret et donc quand
vous irez faire vos courses vous aurez
juste à vous remémorer l'ordre de vos
images donc en images une j'ai un sapin
à ouidah bull et vous allez chercher du
lait en deux j'avais quoi et cetera en
cinq jours à moins qu avec des pattes de
su que j'allais chercher n'est pas après
c'est très facile vous rendez compte
vous n'apprenez plus juste vous
visualisez et votre cerveau stock
naturellement ça permet aussi de retenir
les points clés d'un discours si vous
faites des discours ça permet de retenir
les points clés de n'importe quelle
argumentation si vous devez argumenté
des choses sur une substance dans vos
cours ça permet de se donner des images
aussi pour l'histoire de france pour
tout ce que vous voulez vous pouvez
convertir tous les nombres et les
chiffres voici votre nouveau super
pouvoirs convertissez les nombres les
chiffres en images dans votre tête
stocker les arrêter d'apprendre et
maîtrisez votre mémoire
dans une autre vidéo master class du
samedi disons dans un mois ou deux le
temps que vous maîtrisiez cet outil là
vous apprendrez maintenant l utiliser
pour des choses encore plus hallucinante
pour retenir par exemple lors des quarts
dans un jeu de cartes comme je lé fais
dans une vidéo il ya une méthode qui
existent pour ça mais il faut commencer
par la table de rappel pourrez aussi
vous à prendre comme ça à retenir un mot
qui n'est pas visualisables la confiance
la confiance n'a pas d'image il ya des
astuces qui permettent d'associer des
mots astrée comme confiance amitié
bonheur web ou un nom de médicaments par
exemple à vos images de table de rappel
tout ça on en parlera dans un autre
master class déjà commencé à écrire
votre grille
apprenez la étoffé l'a essayé de la
faire grossir jusqu'à 99 et déjà payé 20
25 30 mois ce sera déjà super j'espère
que cette vidéo master class à elle vous
a plu j'espère surtout vous allez
pouvoir bosser ça et vous en servir au
quotidien je crois que c'est ce qui me
ferait le plus plaisir c'est que ça vous
est d'une manière ou d'une autre à
maîtriser un peu mieux votre mémoire
n'hésitez pas aussi à apprendre ça le
plus tôt possible aux enfants je me dis
que si les enfants maîtriser ce genre
d'outil ce serait beaucoup plus simple
pour eux ensuite
voilà j'espère que cette nouvelle vidéo
vous a plu c'est un nouveau format pour
moi ce sera tous les samedis comme ça
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air
un petit commentaire si vous avez des
questions je me ferais un grand grand
plaisir d'y répondre
abonnez-vous à la chaîne vraiment
vraiment j'attends que vous abonniez et
regarde encore et ça donne pas
abonnez-vous à la chaîne et rendez vous
à demain 11
pour le prochain mentale vlog ciao